because i was like pipe that content
into my ears baby while i'm falling
asleep like i don't i don't even want to
fall asleep i want to be entertained and
pass out
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i
[Music]
matthew mcconaughey
do that
it was awesome yeah apparently matthew
mcconaughey when he wanted to write his
book he drove into the desert like four
hours into the desert and he lit he
literally lived in a shack for two
months and wrote his book
did you read it i read that book or i
read part
um
if you read it and you use matthew
mcconaughey's voice while you're reading
it it's actually pretty entertaining
because it's good stories but also it's
like just stories about his life that
like i'm not sure i care that much about
matthew mcconaughey's life why wouldn't
you just listen to listen to the audible
book then if you wanted his voice to
read it
yeah
i don't know i'm not smart enough
that would have been way better
yeah you should have done the audible
book then
i just honestly didn't think about it it
sounds like a good idea i should
probably do that
so you uh andrew basically uh we'll
we'll do the intro now andrew has is a
great friend of ours has this big
business called tiny uh where they own a
bunch of different businesses north of
100 million ish or so in revenue took a
company public do you you're whatever
you're successful
in terms of career and traditional sense
of successful you're a good friend you
normally come on a lot but you just
tweeted how you kind of like took off
for all of august and you kind of bailed
because you're kind of having a meltdown
in which we all have had before like a
digital overload meltdown and you just
bailed right totally it was it was
really uh it was bad i mean
it's interesting to think about like i
think this happened to everyone over
kovid like their life just shifted in a
weird way um and my life just became
crappy over kovid which is
weird because i had this amazing year
like we took a business public we raised
a big fund we got to work with all these
interesting people we bought some great
businesses i didn't die of covid like
all these great things happened and yet
i was totally miserable
and when i look at it
when i kind of zoom out my old day
i don't know if you guys you guys know
but i live in victoria canada and i
didn't even have an office so i actually
like just working out of cafes i would
just go to the same cafe every day
and i'd sit there with headphones on
three or four of my friends would always
work there so it's kind of like cheers
there's always like interesting people
to talk to
and my day was just broken up into a
bunch of chunks so
any given day i wouldn't really be on
the computer or in one place for more
than an hour or two and my day went from
that to
sitting in a house on my computer all
day
on zoom and doing email
and it just kind of made me miserable
and so
i i um
you know when i look at like what i love
about business
i don't actually love
you know doing business is great doing
strategy coming up with ideas all that
kind of stuff but the cool thing about
business is you get to meet interesting
people like business is just a hack
right so like if you're interested in
health you figure out like a health
business you suddenly can meet all the
most interesting people in that world um
and i'm an extrovert so so anyway just i
was totally bummed and i started um you
know going on twitter a lot because i
was craving socializing um i and i i
went from like 20 000 followers to 170
000 followers so
i got totally hooked into that and like
a good day would be like i have a viral
tweet or i go on your podcast or
something something exciting happens a
bad day would be i say something on
twitter i get dunked on i got
misunderstood or it doesn't do well like
what a ridiculous thing like i'd tweet
and it would only get like 50 likes
instead of 5 000 likes it would like
throw my day off so i got to a point
where i was just like jesus christ like
this is totally ridiculous i'm thinking
about twitter constantly i'm checking
twitter constantly and on top of that
i'm you know email
uh you know checking stats stocks
uh if i went to the bathroom without my
phone i feel like i feel i feel like i
was going to freak out constantly
listening to audiobooks constantly
listening to podcasts no silence so i
just like hit this weird breaking point
august 1st where i woke up
and i was like i'm not stoked to get out
of bed i'm not depressed
objectively everything is fine i'm like
i'm just like i have like anthony like
i'm just not excited about anything so i
just said [__] it i'm just gonna what
what what's that word you just said that
was a good one
yeah it means like an inability to feel
pleasure right like nothing
nothing would get me pumped nothing
would give me a hit like you know you
know when you like you're always you go
on netflix you're like scrolling
endlessly for the perfect thing you just
can't find it that's how my life felt
and so i basically you know it's the
middle of august i live in british
columbia it's super beautiful and so i
just said to my wife you know what i'm
out for the next month let's just go off
to our cabin we'll you know we'll go on
some trips and i'm just going to totally
check out and i set a couple rules for
myself i was like no phone no email no
computer no podcasts
no phone calls no social media no news i
couldn't even read non-fiction business
books right so it's pretty extreme
and i put on my apple watch which has
you know cellular so i was like okay if
there's an emergency i can get a phone
call and i put my phone in a drawer and
i just disappeared i went up to my cabin
and hung out with my kids and honestly
for the first like three or four days it
felt like there was like a bug in my
brain like i was just like so like like
something i i itch i couldn't scratch
like just so irritable as being a huge
[__] uh i was like slapping my pocket
every five seconds to check stuff i'd be
sitting on the beach with my kids and
i'd constantly be like oh i need to text
this to a friend i gotta i gotta take a
photo of this right so it's really weird
horrible withdrawal but then after like
three or four days i was like holy crap
like this is really interesting i
started reading fiction books and just
sitting for hours uh you know enjoying a
sunset taking a silent drive
doing all this stuff
and i think it's kind of like if you eat
junk food all the time like you're
drinking coke and having burgers and
stuff all the time and then you eat
broccoli it doesn't taste that good your
brain is primed for like these extreme
flavors and then if you switch to
broccoli you know you don't eat those
things for a month then you eat broccoli
broccoli is like orgasmic it's amazing
and so anyway i did this for four weeks
and i was feeling really good
and i came back to life like i kind of
reintroduced myself into society and
started going out and working and stuff
and it was really bizarre like i you
know would listen to a song that was
playing in a cafe and it'd be like the
greatest song i've ever heard
i'd read
some random article and it would be like
fascinating and i'd just be completely
uh like just
you know engaged with it um and then
problems i had to solve that would have
pissed me off like
seemed like no problem when i was
excited to solve them and i was kind of
going like man why why did that work
like what was it about that and at the
same time like around then i started
listening to podcasts again and i
listened to this podcast by uh andrew
huberman huberman lab which i'm sure you
guys have listened to he's amazing yeah
he's uh he's coming on the podcast oh
amazing that's that's awesome so he did
this deep dive on addiction
and he did it with this woman anna lemke
who's a stanford addiction doctor and i
was like oh this will be interesting
it'll be about like heroin addiction or
something and how they treat alcoholism
so let's start listening to it those
other people who have those other bad
problems
it's fun it's fun to read about them
totally i was like i was like oh this
will be you know maybe philanthropic you
know i can help fund the heroin
addiction center in victoria or
something so anyway and as i listen i
just go like oh my god like you know
this is not this is universal like
basically the chemical of dopamine the
neurotransmitter is the thing that makes
you feel
craving and pleasure when you do things
and it motivates you to do things
and i realized you know basically like
she said you know something along the
lines of if you eat chocolate cake once
a month it tastes amazing
and you don't really crave it that much
you don't really think about it that
much it's very pleasurable if you eat it
once a week
you know it's still enjoyable but it's
not as good and you start having
cravings you start wanting chocolate
cake if you eat it every day
your brain literally craves it and
you're in pain until you eat it and when
you eat it it's not even that enjoyable
it just makes the pain go away for a
little bit and she compares that to like
heroin addiction or anything and so you
know here we all are we're stimulating
ourselves with social media 24 7 we're
constantly taking these hits and the
hits become less and less enjoyable
and she talked about you know she's at
stanford so she's treating students and
she talked about these kids that would
come in
and they're addicted to social media and
video games and they have no motivation
and so she said look i basically
recommend a dopamine fast for four weeks
they can't do any of that stuff they got
to go walk in silence drive in silence
have quiet moments not avoid those
things and i realized that you know i'd
basically done that
uh for myself and that's why i felt
better and i you know i was an addict
it's crazy
how do you propose doing this though
given like i hear everything you're
saying and i think i actually i'm sure i
have the exact same problem but i'm like
i've got to record this podcast i've got
to text i mean i guess i don't have to
but you know it's easy for you to say a
rich guy right like that right for
somebody who's listening or even most
people i would say
the practicality of detaching for four
weeks
um is hard oh yeah and i think um
my my version of it was extreme but
there's many different forms of it i
mean it could be as simple as you just
wear your apple watch and you don't text
and the only way you text is crappily on
your apple watch you take calls on your
apple watch and you know you do zooms on
your laptop but you just don't have that
constant 24 7 imessage coming in or
maybe you just screen time your phone
super aggressively i mean how do you not
eat junk food all the time and have a
good diet don't keep junk food in the
house don't keep booze in the house
right self-bind yourself um so i mean i
just basically like screen time the hell
out of my phone and like today for
example i drove to my office
i just have my apple watch i don't have
my phone so i know if my kids fall down
and hurt themselves my wife can call me
but otherwise i'm not really texting do
you do that sean because i think of you
sean is someone who
is connected a lot i am connected a lot
i've
consciously picked two parts of my day
where i'm like these are my like
disconnect days you know like these my
disconnect hours at least because you
know i think about it very much the same
as andrea i heard two things that uh
that kind of shifted my view on this so
the first was naval had this great uh
thing he used to say where he goes
the ancient struggle was scarcity you
know the ancient struggle was we just
didn't have enough we didn't have enough
food we didn't have enough water we
didn't have enough um you know access to
medicine entertainment whatever and uh
the modern struggle is abundance which
is where overloaded with cheap dopamine
and like um and then the idea of cheap
dopamine is something that a lot
literally last night i was listening to
hubermann a little clip that came up my
youtube feed of andrew huberman and it's
funny by the way because it's like i
literally i have it's like the addict is
like learning about rehab while like
shooting up basically because it was
3 a.m i had just i was going to bed i
had stayed up way too late already
and i'm the type where you know if i get
like you said i'm going to the bathroom
and i don't have my phone with me i'm
like oh i'm gonna
miss out on like my entertainment like
right now i could watch something listen
to something do something while i'm just
peeing or whatever like brushing my
teeth and i had literally bought this
uh headphone that i can wear to sleep
because it's comfortable so it's like a
headband it's like a soft headband that
has small earbuds baked into it so you
could sleep with headphones because i
was like pipe that content into my ears
baby while i'm falling asleep like i
don't i don't even want to fall asleep i
want to be entertained and pass out like
that's kind of the way i was sleeping
and so even last night i was doing that
my bad habit
and it was just like you know ultra
connected too connected and i started
listening to superman thing and he goes
he said something that really struck me
he goes he goes one way to think about
addiction is it's a progressive
narrowing of what gives you pleasure
um so it's a it's a uh you are narrowing
the things in your life that that will
give you this rush of pleasure so andrew
when you when you when you dopamine
fasted you started getting pleasure from
silence in the car from the sunset from
fiction books but before that it's like
twitter was this cheap fast
instantaneous guaranteed source of
pleasure and so it was it narrowed the
number of places you were going to get
that pleasure to like this most common
over time
it also became more painful though more
like when i first started doing twitter
it was pure pleasure so fun and then
over time it took more and more of a hit
to satisfy me the numbing and then yeah
you get numb to the sort of like you you
build up tolerance right like you would
with alcohol or anything else
and of course you had to turn your
you turned your experience into a thread
which probably became one of your most
uh reached of course
totally totally well and this is the
debate right is do you want to engage
like okay like obviously it's a good
thing that we can all uh use imessage
and use these devices like they're
they're a bicycle for the mind there's
all these amazing things you can do you
can meet all these amazing people but
the question is how to use them in a
responsible way so like on twitter i
have a one-way twitter client that i'm
using so i don't actually see the
results of my tweets right although in
this case i'll admit i did when i did go
and look but my goal is to actually
fully screen time on every device so i
can't access twitter only the uh the api
i think there's here's a good way to
look at it so have you guys heard of
this person named uh earl nightingale
so basically he probably died in the 60s
maybe he died in the 70s and he was
famous in the 50s and 60s and he
basically was almost like a tony robbins
of that era but he was a little bit more
well known as like a writer he was like
um almost like a like a like a dan
rather's meets
uh tony robbins mainstream famous guy
and he told this famous story on this on
his radio broadcast where he talked to a
farmer and he went to this farmer's
house and this was right when the
telephone got popular he went to this
farmer's house and he's talking and
they're just having this conversation
and the phone starts ringing and the
farmer doesn't flinch he just keeps
making eye contact and having uh the
conversation and about five minutes
later the phone rings again and does the
same thing he keeps making eye eye
contact and then a few minutes later it
rings one more time and the guys uh the
guests go earl goes hey do you need to
answer that and the farmer goes
what that thing no no that's just there
for my convenience uh i i answer that
whenever i want and whenever i heard
that story a couple years ago i was like
that's how i'm going to treat my phone
it is there for me and so i don't feel
guilty about clicking ignore deny or
don't not replying it is this this thing
this phone it exists for my convenience
not the other way around i i own it well
the other thing is you know do you ever
think well like the 1950s so in the
1950s if you're an executive at a
business you would a have a secretary
right and the secretary would be keeping
everyone away from you and then you'd
get your mail once or twice a day and so
you'd batch it right so you'd get 100
letters
half of them would be done by your
secretary you get
20 or
50 of them or whatever you just do that
over an hour you write all your letter
responses then you're done for the day
whereas what we have is a mailman who's
coming to the door every five minutes
knock knock knock here throwing a bunch
more letters in there and you're kind of
doing it in the middle of everything so
i think like batching also is incredibly
helpful the other thing is like you know
people who talk about being friends with
their family with an alcoholic they talk
about how the alcohol will will actually
if someone gets in in between them and
the alcohol they will
always choose the alcohol and i think
the hard part is you know you think
about
and think about all the
arguments i've had with my with my wife
where if i don't get to follow my
routine my dopamine routine of well i
like to listen to podcasts in the shower
and then i like to do x and y and z and
i've got my whole routine and process if
she would mess with it like hey i've got
i need you to go and do this or whatever
i would like rage right and i just
thought i was an [__] or ocd or
something and then now being off of that
i'm not raging and getting frustrated in
that same way so it's really fascinating
all the addiction stuff just really
flows through this
i've created basically three two windows
in the day so uh exercise is one
exercise is beautiful because uh you
know
i have a very low urge to check my phone
when i'm working out anyways so that
becomes a full kind of like almost 90
minutes of
uh of not looking at my phone and i
don't care what's happening and i don't
care who's i don't care how much sales
we have i don't care you know who's
mentioning me i don't care who's
emailing me slacking me
um and so sam i think you probably have
the same where would you work out i
don't think you are checking your phone
uh during it yeah i don't i it means
nothing to me i do look at it to mark
down what i'm doing uh but typically
what i've been doing lately is i'll mark
down on a notepad with my workout and
then i transfer it after the workout
specifically so i don't touch my phone
you guys listen to music while you work
out because one of the things huberman
talks about is you don't want a dopamine
stack so people work out to experience
pleasure and dopamine but if you start
stacking it so you say i when i work out
i watch game of thrones and i get a
smoothie after
and and and you start to not enjoy the
actual workout whereas if you do it for
intrinsic reasons you can actually train
yourself to enjoy it right
i do that because i listen to music too
and i like i love the
like that's i feel like that's music
listening time
you know what i mean we're basically i'm
here i am training i am going to love
your addiction
you watching
sorry go ahead
that's funny andrew say i'm i'm getting
between you in your addiction sam raged
out immediately um you know the
i'm i'm doing the opposite where uh like
dan ariely the kind of like famous
behavioral
economist he was talking about this
thing where he had this medicine he had
to take because he has really bad burns
he had really bad facial burns he had to
take this one medicine all the time or
apply this ointment it burned it was
like really uncomfortable and so he was
like instead of trying to
wrestle the brain and convince the brain
through logic that this is a good thing
for me when the brain is just saying ew
this i don't like the way this medicine
makes me feel don't take this um he's
like i just attached a really i think i
really loved uh to taking the medicine
so every time i take the medicine i
would take it during the intro of my
favorite movie and i would watch my
favorite movie or my favorite show and
he's like that helped me stick to my
routine of taking the medicine actually
get healthier and so for me that's
almost like working out where working
out wasn't something i found super
pleasurable that's why i didn't work out
for so long because it kind of felt like
work and so i had to retrain myself
using music having a great trainer who i
like hanging out with you know like
doing different types of workouts that
are more sporty so that i would actually
get pleasure from working out so i would
actually like it so i stacked it
intentionally i stacked things i knew i
loved onto working out so that i started
to love working out because i only got
to do those things when i worked out
yeah and i i'd also say though andrew um
well you're taking the stance i don't
know if you actually feel that way is
addiction necessarily bad like all right
so i had i've talked about this one i've
had like alcohol problems and then i
started like going to cigars like one
way that i got off it is i started
smoking and then like after smoking i
like started doing sugar or something
like that and i went to the doctor and
she's like
i was like you know i'm eating so much
sugar and she's like well is it helping
you not drink i go yeah she goes i'm
gonna [__] it just do it and uh i'm like
yeah why wouldn't i just do that and so
some addiction i i'm whenever i think of
like i'm like
just it's not necessarily bad like so
like if you're addicted to one thing or
the other well is that is that like does
it kind of make you a little bit happy
you know i think actually some addiction
can be okay that's kind of
there's there's a lot of different
levels to it right like i think
obviously heroin alcohol drug abuse that
leads to a life of guaranteed misery
very quickly and you die young and
you're depressed and everything else but
the fundamental question is if you're
addicted to work
and it's making you depressed then you
know just because you're objectively
achieving whatever you're achieving if
you're depressed right so i think that's
the way i would think about it
um
what's the highest order bit right if
the highest order bit is that i'm
feeling good on a daily basis i enjoy my
life i feel i feel good then cool
whatever your system is is serving you
but as soon as that spirals out and it
might start that way the same behavior
might start feeling that way and then
all of a sudden
it's you stop feeling that that's what
kind of happened with you andrew is like
let's say like at first you were getting
this great pleasure and rush from
connecting with people on twitter and
sharing your ideas and that's fun and
you were helping people because people
heard those ideas and took them for
their own
and then like you know everything in
excess sort of has the the cons will
sort of reveal themselves over time
totally well another the other thing
that's interesting is like i'm the kind
of person where i'm always hacking
everything right so i was like okay if i
do the dishes i found a way to enjoy the
dishes so i'm stacking on i've got my
podcast i've got my music i get my treat
after you know all those things and
recently what i've been trying to do is
just do the best job of doing the dishes
i possibly can in silence it's almost a
meditative practice and what i've
noticed is again the first couple times
i did it i was raging i was like this
[__] sucks i don't want to do the
dishes you know this is bs and then
after a while of just silently doing the
dishes i started really enjoying it and
now when my wife says can you do the
dishes i don't get irritable and i'm not
expecting a treat and i'm doing it
because it's intrinsically enjoyable
feeling the hot water and washing the
pan and doing a good job which sounds
ridiculous but it's no different than
gardening or any other thing that people
like it's just tuning your brain for it
so can we talk about something that
doesn't seem similar but kind of is but
basically andrew you bought this company
aeropress which is actually like in my
opinion probably one of the best
companies that you could own if you are
trying not to get addicted to uh
fast twitch uh notifications alerts
because it's been around forever it you
do you guys even sell anything
do you even sell it online really other
than amazon a little bit only i think
it's like three percent of sales are
online right now so like it's a pretty
like low
stress
like because you haven't built anything
new or aeropress is it's basically a if
you don't know what aeropress is it's a
coffee maker that's been the same way
since the beginning is that right yeah
it's been around since i think 2006 and
it's like this it looks like a pvc tube
and you press down on you put some
coffee in the bottom of it you put some
hot water and you press down and it
makes like a concentrated coffee and uh
it's been around yeah for for a long
time and it was started by the guy who
made the aerobee frisbee he's like a
serial inventor so that those like neon
pink frisbees from the 80s
um yeah it's it's an amazing product can
you say what you bought it for
uh the deal was 70 million uh 70 million
to buy it
and can you say how big it i mean what
can you say about it it wasn't for sale
or this was one that you were like let
me see if i can if they're willing to
sell
so
i mean uh basically the story is
four or five years ago i was making
coffee i've been using aeropress for
years we had one at our office someone
brought brought one in like 10 years ago
and i looked down at it and i was like
oh man i wonder who owns this so i
started googling i realized the founder
still owned it and he is this 80 year
old serial inventor who lives in palo
alto so i sent him an email i looked up
his email on voila norbert and i said
hey can i come to palo alto and you know
would you ever explore selling and he
said i don't know if i want to sell but
i'm happy to meet you and so i flew down
and chris and i spent a whole day with
him just kind of talking about the
business
um and there's just so much to love
about this business so what was he like
he's like this like really funny old guy
he reminded me a little bit of my
grandpa uh you know he had hearing aids
he he like just clearly loved inventing
and coming up with ideas and he started
walking me through you know all the
different inventions and ideas that he
had and things he wanted to make
did he actually work there
yeah yeah yeah he um so he really like
ran he was really responsible for
inventing in the product and then he had
a president who was running the
day-to-day business um
and so
uh you know this is like it's such a
crazy business so there's zero marketing
so they spend absolutely nothing on
marketing um it's sold in pretty much
every single gourmet coffee shop in the
world like you walk into anywhere blue
bottle from down to like little
independent ones everyone sells it um
it's very very uh like um
it's like it's a a category owner i
would call it right so
if you think about like a commodity
product even like kleenex or band-aid
right it is the it's it's the category
defining brand right so no one searches
like pneumatic tube coffee maker they
just search aeropress so um and it's
literally written on grinders right so
like one of the settings on the grinders
aeropress so basically this is an
opportunity for us to buy a category of
like making coffee a way of making
coffee um and like people are fanatical
there's like world aeropress
championships baristas get like tattoos
of aeropresses like it's totally nuts so
anyway
i spent four years trying to convince
him to sell his business and i literally
emailed him every single month for four
years i'd call this the dennis the
menace just like i have an email
reminder and superhuman and i just kept
asking and then finally uh you know over
the last six months we negotiated a deal
and got it done and the idea is very
simple i mean this is an incredible
product
it's really just about selling it in
more places and they really just didn't
have a ddc strategy so we're basically
coming in we're going to focus on d to c
and keep the business as it is otherwise
and just scale that channel so we're
super excited about it
what you just said that's wild to me
when uh
i think he said this on the podcast i
think i could share it when uh
when moyes ali was selling native and
native at the time was just uh just a
deodorant um that's all they sold one
one one one product with a couple of uh
scents or flavors
and um and so it was like a
you know here's this this um paraben
free aluminum-free deodorant and he's
going to be selling and like part of the
sales pitch of like how to get more
upside in the deal was hey right now
we're doing so well with just deodorant
imagine if we expanded or whatever
that's kind of like the the high level
idea but i thought the way he said it
makes a big difference so like it was
wonderful he and this is like i call
this out because i you know when i teach
this power writing course i live for
these phrases these
let's take the same information let's
say it two different ways and watch what
happens and so you know one is there's
lots of room to expand into other
product lines okay emotionally registers
as a one and then the the uh the way he
said it when he was meeting with
somebody they were like well
how big can this the other thing be and
like you know what's the upside here for
us he goes he goes um do you know how to
write the word native on other bottles
he's like like if could you write that
on a shampoo bottle could you write that
on a toothpaste bottle and he's like
that's your upside and
it's like you know
obviously kind of a funny [__] thing
to say but
it really like hits home and so when you
when i was hearing about the aeropress
thing i it reminded me of that which is
like
you know do you know how to make a
website because right now if it's all if
it's all done not through d2c not done
online it's like it doesn't take a
genius to make this like the genius
thing was buying it not making it better
and bigger than it is today and that's
like your sweet spot right is you're not
looking to be a genius
yeah there's this period where factories
went from being steam powered to powered
by electricity right and you could
basically go and you could buy a factory
and convert it there's a lot of money
being made to be made in just
electrification in factories or products
or anything and this is one of those
things right where you find a business
that's using a legacy
sales process via retail which we're
going to keep i mean it's an amazing
advertising mechanism and we love all
the distributors and everything but at
the same time it's like hey we can also
sell sddc awesome and it's such a simple
insight that we don't need to be
geniuses a even if we don't do as great
as we think we'll still do fine we'll
have a great business and if we do well
we're going to blow the doors up
one more point on that that you bought
it for 70 million dollars what is the
annual ruffle roughly the annual
marketing and advertising spend that has
created this business that you bought
for 70 million dollars is it
or less than one million dollars
yeah so it's like 20 000 exactly so i
mean here's the other one right if you
include salaries there's there's a few
people in the marketing but let's call
it if you include salaries maybe let's
call it 150 200 grand hold on how many
people are in there why do you have a
marketing person if you're spending
twenty thousand dollars yeah why does
there are salaries
well they do do what they do is lots of
like um i wouldn't even call it
influencer but like they do a lot of pr
and outreach but the company the company
this company is it's like it's like
[__] carmex or something it's like
you made it one time and then like
what
when i imagine a business like this what
do the people do every day like do you
have like
like you know roughly how many orders
the hustle i used to be like why do you
have 25 people here you write one email
and you're like yeah it just it takes a
lot of people to like you know make this
email great and like have ads well for
us
for us it was redundancy you needed
redundancy because because it relied it
was a it was a digital thing that people
made every single day and i actually
think you could run the whole business
with 15 people or less but with
aeropress you probably could do did you
only need like ten or five or how many
people did yesterday i think there's sub
ten employees wow and they're managing
the distributors and making sure
manufacturing is good and all that kind
of stuff that's crazy and so a five or
ten person company for 70 million
dollars that's freaking awesome that's
so cool like you you know what carmex is
andrew it's the like the challenge the
lip balm yeah yeah this is it's like
this is like one of those you i think
you up here you call it a cruise ship
this is one of those things where just
it just does the same thing like you
guys didn't create anything new after
the initial thing right
no no we haven't done anything explain
this cruise ship investing philo
framework what is this
well okay so i think um
when i talk to any young person and you
know myself included i really glorified
startups right and i i i like to kind of
turn these into like um
analogies or whatever just so they're
easy to explain and i was like oh you
know
a startup is really like a speedboat
right it's exhilarating it can go
anywhere but at the end of the day you
know you're driving over waves you're
getting your you know body destroyed
you're freezing cold
you might hit a rock you might get drunk
you really have to be white knuckling
and pay attention and you're constantly
worried you're going to run out of gas
right so i was like okay so that's a
startup
a cruise ship is slow and steady it
moves on a straight course so you can
pretty much estimate where they're going
you can make an educated guess that
you'll end up in hawaii versus
antarctica based on where they're going
and what their course is
and you can get a comfortable sleep lots
of amenities there's very low odds of
failure it's not dangerous at all and
best of all you don't have to buy the
whole boat you just buy a ticket and i
was saying you know a stock certificate
right so essentially i just as a mental
model i go i when i look at a business i
go is this a speed boat or a cruise ship
do i need to be white knuckling this and
do i need a you know amazing captain
or can i just go and board a cruise ship
that's already doing really well
and it's much more boring to ride a
cruise ship no one's going to give you
an award or write a book about you for
having an amazing
crossing of the atlantic or whatever on
a cruise ship but it's very comfortable
and enjoyable
so i've just been using that example
when i talk to young entrepreneurs
there's a similar example to that so
this guy named joel uh what's the the
guy who started um joel on software um
yeah joel on software withdrawal and
software what does it call it so what's
the thing that ev everyone knows
uh trello
sack overflow yeah so this guy he's he's
amazing so his name is joel on software
his blog if you want to read good
writing it's this guy it's called
joelandsoftware.com it's amazing and
he's got this amazing blog post where he
talks about different strategies and he
basically calls it the ben jerry's or
the amazon and so with amazon it's new
competition or sorry new technology and
there's very little competition at first
and you basically need to go balls to
the wall like a speed boat you need to
go as hard as you possibly can early on
to grab as much market share you're okay
with losing a lot of money and you know
it's um and you gotta go fast otherwise
you're gonna lose and it's a zero-sum
game or there's ben and jerry's where
there's already a lot of ice cream
competition you can go to a bunch of
different ice cream places throughout
the week and it's no big deal and if you
do a good job this could last for 50 or
100 years um and that's kind of like the
different strategies although i would
say that the cruise ship analogy is
probably even better
totally i wanted to ask you uh you said
something about the cruise ship thing
which was like you know you don't get to
be the hero because you didn't you know
white knuckle uh and like
um survive the the crazy storm and come
out the other side which is like you
know the startup founder who pulls it
off and disrupts the industry and blah
blah and you had a thing on here which i
think is more related to your twitter
stuff but i think they're they're both
the same they're both uh they're both
related which is what's the perfect
amount of notoriety so what's the
perfect amount of fame and to what
extent do you
do you um
do things in order to build your profile
build your build your frame right so
what are your kind of like most what's
your most up-to-date thoughts on that
because i think you've done a good job
right you do have a high profile you
have a higher profile than i don't know
of people who do what you do which is
private equity um and you know so so
you've done a good job in that and i
think that's paid work dividends and
it's probably had fun you know uh ego
dividends too where you feel good about
it um but you know there's downsides so
what do you what do you think now what
do you think's the perfect amount of
notoriety
well this one i'm trying to figure out
and i i don't really know if i have the
answer and i think you guys have
probably gonna gone through this exact
same thing as i have i mean i was
sitting in a cafe my my wife was like
hey you know go take go take a couple
hours to yourself and so i went and i
sat at a cafe and i was reading a book
and a friend showed up i started talking
to him
your wife just said go take a couple
hours for yourself could i just the mvp
of uh look
what's going on i need to tell my wife
this is a thing
this is because i haven't been irritable
right because i'm not an addict right
now
um
so anyways i'm sitting there and
chatting with my friend and you know i'm
sharing personal stuff and you know
talking about what's going on in my life
and maybe 20 minutes into our
conversation there's this guy who's
sitting to our left and he goes hey i'm
really sorry to interrupt but i heard
you on my first million
and i've got a business over in
vancouver
and that was so cool right like that's
i'm sure you guys have that too every
once in a while someone else is that is
that a real story by the way yes 100
real that's awesome there's the guy i'll
mention the guy he runs a uh he runs the
best gourmet coffee shop at ubc which is
a big university in vancouver uh it's
called bulldog coffee and i was like wow
that's actually genius you've basically
gotta capture you've captured a market
that's smart but anyway
what was going through my head after
that is oh my god what did i say like
you know here's this person who heard
everything i was saying i don't think i
said anything bad or you know overly
personal but there is this sense of like
oh there's a loss of privacy and not
only that but you have to be consistent
so if i go on this podcast and i say i'm
about x and y and z now every time i
talk to someone if i change my mind or i
want to be kind of a chameleon and just
be a different person or whatever like
they almost like call you out or
whatever so it's just it's it's very
interesting and some of the other
downside is that i'm sure you guys have
had is consistency and commitment bias
right so an example is i talked about
the um
sugar-free bakery thing i was doing and
we ended up getting uh we weren't
legally allowed to use a key ingredient
in canada until it's approved so i was
like okay i have to shut this down but i
didn't shut it down for like two months
longer than i should have because i'd
gone on here and made a public statement
to everyone hey everyone look i'm doing
this this awesome thing and i felt
ashamed it was like in a logi in a
logical thing um there's this great
quote by bill murray that said if you
think you want to be rich and famous try
being rich first and see if that covers
it and i think that that's really
interesting and i
i think like you want to be respected in
your world you want to be like in the in
film you'd want to be like the coen
brothers right where it's like no one
knows what the coen brothers look like
but if they're at the academy words
they're like ballers and they can get
the attention and do whatever they want
i don't think do you know what dad do
you know who daft punk is
yeah oh dude dude i was like they've got
the best job because i mean they don't
even have to show up and they probably
make 10 million each a year just help
these concerts because the edm or
whatever the genre is they've they're
huge concerts i'm like they don't even
have to show up they could be anyone
underneath that mask that could be
anyone
totally i think it's super smart
and i don't i don't know what i mean
what do you guys think
sam you've shared some stories about
being stopped in the street and stuff
yeah i get sean do you get stopped i get
stopped probably uh once or twice a week
i don't think our audience is big in uh
the suburbs of california so you know my
my neighbors like average age is like 70
probably or something so i don't think
these guys are listening but what's cool
is like my trainer he came to me the
other day and he's like i met these two
guys in the gym they're like 21 22 years
old
and they were telling me like oh dude
you gotta listen to this podcast
it's like we're hooked on it and then
we're getting so many ideas we're going
to quit our job we're going to do the
stuff and um and they should they're
like he's like what's the podcast and it
was like my first million he's like bro
that's my buddy like that's that's why
trey i'm going there right after this
and they're like no way and so it's more
of these like secondhand stories that
have either a happened to me or b like
kind of light me up a little bit like i
mentioned my cousin's name on the last
podcast because jack a jack who was on
the podcast had invested in him and uh
he's like dude he's like i know you do a
podcast or i know you mention me the
podcast because i'll just get a bunch of
messages being like oh somebody you know
he shouted you out or can we invest in
your thing he's like it's amazing how
much
instant like kind of um you know love i
get if you just say my name or say our
company's name on the pod and those are
cool moments
yeah the serendipity like i talked about
this idea sam and i were riffing on like
um you know what business would you
start if you could start anything today
or just throwing out ideas and one of
them was
ddc pregnancy health so how do you build
a super baby using supplements and blood
work and all that kind of stuff and now
i'm in partnership with this woman named
katie dewhurst and we're working on this
business together and it's been super
fun and i never would have been able to
do that and i literally you know met the
best possible person for that idea i
never would have been able to do that so
it's like the pros are huge but then the
cons are those kind of odd things or for
you guys i would assume you're probably
addicted to your podcast stats right oh
where are we ranking on the itunes no
well i would say we do i'm more addicted
to twitter i think yeah so like i i was
like oh i'm gonna be slick and turn off
my notifications but what i do is i
search the sampar my twitter handle like
i search that and then type in latest so
it's like i see my face
yeah like i'm like so uh that kind of
like that's stupid
podcast is not podcast is not designed
to be addictive because you don't get
these like viral spurts uh it's slow and
steady compounding with no immediate
feedback you don't get comments after
every episode like and that makes it
suck and there's a lot of bad things
about that but the good thing is it's
very zen and so like of all the things
i've done newsletter twitter and i've
like tried to be successful in them try
to grow them gotten some growth gotten
to success gotten made money off of them
and they all i like fade out because i'm
like
you know
i don't like what this does to me you
know i i i think one of the most toxic
things you can do is care too much what
other people think of you and it's
fundamentally the loop of what social
media is is you post something and then
other people react to your either your
photo what i look like what i sound like
or what i said or what i thought right
and so
karen you know i hate
tweeting something and then wanting to
go check the mentions check the reaction
to it
because fundamentally i'm putting all my
awareness and attention to what do other
people think about me and that's it
that doesn't have to be that it doesn't
have to be bad so let me give you an
example andrew you probably don't know
this but i'm a fitness influencer now
i've got four thousand so i here like i
was i kind of did it as a joke but kind
of not so basically
uh i this the year of 2021 i wanted to
work really hard to get very very very
fit and i had a hit a little bit of a
plateau and i was joking with sean but i
kind of wasn't joking i was like i'm
just gonna start posting on instagram
constantly and just because i'm gonna
change my identity to become a fitness
person and i've been doing it lately
and it's obviously it's not a big deal
like no one actually watches but
it's made me
not eat certain foods because i'm like i
i said i posted that i was gonna hit
this weight and these people are like
it's not real but in my head these
people are expecting me to do it i have
to come with the results so i can make
fill this make this story complete and
you know like be like the love of their
lives and like get their attention and
is that unhealthy kind of but i'm
getting a great result
yeah well i think um we got to talk
about this
book i read called wanting have you guys
heard of this book no no
have you ever heard so peter thiel talks
about mimesis or memetic desire have you
guys heard about this concept yeah he
talks about like renee's gerard or
whatever renee gerard i buy the books
and i'm like i can't [__] read this
it's so dense like i know it's like a
french david david
david perrell did a bunch of articles
about it and even then it's just too
dense it's too academic i didn't get it
and finally you know one of my friends
who's like super into peter thiel gave
me this book wanting and it was kind of
a revelation for me so the idea is
basically that you want the things
that are modeled to you by other people
so you know you meet a friend at a bar
you want a beer here there's a martini
maybe you go oh maybe i do want a
martini right so that's that's like the
most
generic example of like a meaningless
thing what about if your friend tells
you he just raised around from sequoia
capital right you start asking yourself
why didn't i raise from sequoia why
don't you know why does his startup have
more employees than mine does why didn't
i get that job title he has a sailboat
why don't i have a sailboat why don't i
have a rolex he moves to brooklyn
why don't i live in brooklyn right so
basically when you surround yourself
with peers you start competing with them
and you start wanting those things and
you know i see this in my own group of
friends uh you know when one of us buys
a new car within a year we've all bought
a new car right there's these waves or
the other thing you see is mirroring so
you know let's say i buy a tesla my
friend might say i'm buying a classic
ford mustang and i'm going to constantly
talk about how much i love the rumble of
the engine or working on it right it's
like this like counter
mirror um so it's super interesting
because you don't actually want these
things these are not real desires these
are modeled to you and so in this book
they talk about thin desires so these
are like extrinsic things coming from
the modeling of others right so wanting
a rolex because people you know that are
your peers value rolexes
and then there's thick desires which are
intrinsic they come from inside of you
so you enjoy working in your garden you
don't need to tell anyone you don't post
about it it's not part of your identity
you don't do it to impress anyone it's
just something you quietly enjoy and so
i think the big thing is coming up with
what are my thick desires what are real
versus what come from wanting to be like
my heroes or
my friends or whoever it is because if
you're not careful of pruning this you
will become this and if you spend too
much time around people who want things
that you don't actually want you will
still desire and achieve those things
so i love what you're saying keep going
so you read this book and then there's
like the question of what are your
models who are your models
and what did you you know what did you
take away from this so yeah i mean like
are you jealous of jeff bezos
no jeff bezos is not someone that you
compete with right jeff bezos is off in
this celebrity world right jay-z that's
not someone you compete with right the
people you compete with are people
within your bubble like it could be each
other us three maybe there's other
things that there could be other things
that people are more jealous i i
guarantee you anyone who's on twitter
for example anyone on twitter in
business you know you and the morning
brew guys like it doesn't matter if you
like them or anything you're still in a
memetic competition when i see sam's
post as a fitness influencer you bet
your ass i work out harder that day
totally well and exactly he now values
health so that's that's good if you want
to be healthy hanging out with sam will
probably make you healthier over time
right so that's a good thing um but so
you know and there's so many different
bubbles there's so many different worlds
so for example if you live in san
francisco the
thing that everyone wants is you know
fundraising and valuation or who your
investors are if you're in new york it
might be about your wealth your art
collection or your fashion
in la it would be you know what awards
have you won where do you get restaurant
reservations uh you know athletes it's
olympic medals chefs it's michelin stars
comedians with netflix specials uh you
know you you name it so the way to
figure out who your models are as well
is actually to ask kind of an odd
question you say who do i not want to
succeed right and maybe it's deep within
you right but it might be that guy on
twitter who you know you're friendly
with and everything's fine but you kind
of he bothers you or he's maybe a little
ahead of you has maybe ten thousand more
followers you just don't want him to
succeed that's probably who you're in
memetic rivalry with um and and so the
real question is you know how do you a
align with people who
will lead you down a path of this
mimetic copying that will actually make
you happy so that's spending time with
people who are actually similar to you
and want things that are your thick
desires right being healthy being safe
gardening you know whatever that is
and then the other question is how do
you opt out um and and really that's
pruning you know what do you read who do
you listen to who do you spend time with
um and you know for an example i thought
about for myself you know i was spending
all this time reading about warren
buffett i've idolized warren buffett
forever but when i think about you know
what does warren buffett actually do in
his day
he's a guy who can sit there and read
all day reading annual reports that's
what his life is set up for i would kill
myself like i have no interest in doing
that and i think i'd be very bored so i
have to be very careful not to over
index on warren buffett
the other thing you can do is you can
opt out so you can say you know i'm
going to be like dave chappelle i'm
going to move to ohio where i'm just you
know a redneck and you know in a small
community or whatever for me i live in
victoria you know i'm not as exposed to
this as other people
and there's this great story of this guy
who's a michelin
star chef so you think about chefs the
ultimate is you open a restaurant and a
really high-end restaurant you get a
michelin star this guy sebastian brass
did that all he wanted was to get a
michelin star and he got it and when he
got it it didn't actually make him
happier he just wanted a second star
then he got a second star it didn't make
him happy either and he just lived in
fear of losing it because they just come
and inspect you you know it'll be like
they'll come to your restaurant and if
the tablecloth isn't perfectly clean or
the food is in a certain way you know
you get rejected and so you end up
living your life by these arbitrary
rules that don't actually make you happy
and you fight for something that you
know is not what you actually want so
this guy is a baller he just said
michelin i want you to remove my star
take me out of the guide i'm out right
so you can do stuff like that but that
takes like brass balls that's very
difficult to do
why did you mention read why i mean
you're talking about reading and
everything and i want to ask you what
you're reading why did you mention
read-wise uh on your document
well i think like you know i'm like you
guys i just read all sorts of random
stuff and i'll read all these books
that'll make a huge impact on me but
then i'll forget everything right and so
i use this tool called read wise where
my kindle highlights basically get
emailed to me once a day at random and
it's like uh there's like a memory uh
thing called spaced repetition and so it
basically sends you uh you know every
week every month i'll get all these
ideas back boomerang back to me and i
just kind of am reminded of some of
these things i've read when you're
reading do you just read book after book
yeah usually what i i do that as well
i'm thinking that's actually really
stupid if i find like a book that like
has a big impact or as like has a ton of
learnings i should probably reread that
every handful of months or something
like
you know you you you should do whatever
it takes to really understand and grasp
and assigned reading not as much like go
from thing to thing to thing you know
what i mean you know do you know what
the feynman method is no it's basically
you you read the thing and then you
teach it and you can't truly understand
it until you teach it so like a way of
remembering really well would be go on
the podcast and in a very cogent way
summarize what you've learned and then
keep bringing it up for yourself right
like i i mean you know just even writing
out some notes for this podcast it
forced me to actually go what did i
learn in this book and i'm sure it'll
actually hammer it into my head better
that's how i used to be in college uh
i didn't know that that was a technique
but i had figured out pretty early on
that the way i could
get better grades like i wanted to have
good grades but i didn't want to keep
studying as my other i felt like other
people studied so much they spent so
many hours in the library and i just
didn't find it i didn't want to do it
and i was like well here's what i'll do
i'll basically
quickly skim the material and then i
will lead a study group where i'll teach
it to that group and in that process i
was like a horrible teacher for the
first like hour when i was doing it
because i don't know the material yet i
actually don't even understand it i
barely remember half of it but i
remember half of it and like by teaching
it i remembered that half and i quickly
figured out the other half i didn't know
and i just remember like that's how i
studied for every final when i was in
college and it was um
it was pretty amazing because i could
study half the time as other people
because what they would do is they would
try to just ingest it and just keep
ingesting it they just try to keep
reading it and rereading it and writing
notes and rereading it and they would
never try to
articulate it off the top of their head
to anybody else or answer a question you
know in public with anybody else and so
they never did that and they just tried
to like solidify it in their head but it
never really did um you know for them or
took way longer to do it
it's such a hack right to be able to
summarize it in one sentence or have a
you know have a metaphor or you know
whatever it is
can you do that just by writing a blog
post about it or do you actually have to
speak about it oh you could do that
i i used to run this thing called the
anti-mba and it was a weekly book club
basically we would read a book a month
and each week we would divide that book
into quarters so we'd talk about a book
every week and i would basically be
leading this and we would have 10 or 20
people show up and i would lead it and i
remember i learned like crazy every book
i was like mastering it but i wasn't
sure if i could do that now just through
blogging or if i actually had to like
organize and talk to people about it
because that'd be a pain in the ass
one thing i've seen is my uh
uh
i don't know this is kind of an
unpopular uh way to think or something i
don't know i don't think this is the
this is how much people think but listen
like andrew so i think andrew i think
you're super smart and amazing and great
and i love when you bring these ideas
because it makes me feel like it brings
all these new thoughts into my head um
but i think you and i think sam to an
extent do something that i used to do
that i'm trying to stop doing and that
is like um
this constant optimization
and so like you know this idea that i'm
going to read a book i'm going to find a
great book and then sam's like i'm going
to reread it because i want it to sink
in i'm gonna drill it into my head and
andrew's like no what i do is i
highlight using this tool and i set up
an auto trigger to email me back the
best highlights like
old me would have been like
dope love that that's gonna be my
solution
to this like underlying ever present
problem i'm going to keep seeking these
solutions that are like
new hacks new optimizations new like
kind of techniques and solutions and
methods
and um and the one like realization i've
had by talking to some other people
outside my trainer is really the one who
drilled this in me because he would be
talking to me during a workout he would
say something to me i would go run to my
notepad i would write it down because he
said this really wise thing and it was
so good i wanted to like remember it as
a nugget of gold
and he told me he goes he goes you know
you you won't have to write these down
um
and i go i go what do you mean also how
nerdy of you to be writing this down i
would literally stop a set and i would
drop the weight and i would go write the
thing down because i'm like you just
said it so perfectly and in my head i'm
like i'm gonna know this i'm gonna
remember this i'm gonna tell other
people i'm gonna say this on the pod
it's gonna look great my head actually
is silently thinking all these other
things it's like trying to like achieve
some stupid goal because i'm like this
is the answer this is the nugget that's
going to be my next hit my next tweet my
next whatever that's going to be great
so that's like you know a lame thing to
admit but that's true that's where my
brain was going um but i was like what
do you mean i'll have to write these
down like you know i'll just remember it
and he's like you won't feel like you
lack something and so you'll stop like
trying to catch everything and grab
everything and hold on to everything and
learn the next new thing
what you'll realize is like
you already know the answers uh he's
like you know it's like a thin book you
didn't like imagine a book that ended in
20 pages and it's like you know for for
a diet book right you can keep searching
for the next fad diet you know the
atkins diet then the slow carb diet and
then the carnivore diet and you're
you're just cycling through to all these
different diets trying to find the next
solution and read the next thing
and in reality you kind of know the
answer the answer is you know don't eat
too much and eat like basically like eat
real food
mostly plants and not too much
three lines you that is the answer and
but instead of actually just let sitting
in it you want it to be more complicated
than that you would like it to be
that actually there is more i need to go
learn and find and try and buy this you
know get this app that's going to do my
intermittent fasting and then put this
ketone
drops in my drink and then wear a patch
that measures my glucose monitor and
like all these optimizations and so i've
actually spent so much of my life trying
these different optimizations and i've
really i'm just saying this as almost
like a public service announcement of
like if that's you if you've done a
bunch of these optimizations you're kind
of on this endless path of optimizing
and you do get results it's not that you
don't get any results
but like
i've now found this like other way
that's a lot more peaceful and a lot
more fun and it's basically um
get rid of the underlying
like feeling of lack
and doubt that you have that's causing
you to constantly chase the next best
method and solution and answer
i think that really resonates and one of
the things i didn't talk about was my
routines and how that was making me
miserable
i think often routines are great and
best practices are great but they end up
creating conditions under which you can
have a good day and if you don't follow
the conditions your brain starts saying
oh it's not a good day because i didn't
get that workout in or i didn't get i
didn't do my cold plunge and do my tim
ferris tea in the morning i didn't do my
evernote
routine i didn't do a gratitude journal
i didn't use this app right there's
endless things um and i totally resonate
with that like one of the practices for
me was like how do i not check my aura
ring how do i not check my blood glucose
all these stupid things that are giving
me they're tickers right yeah there you
go like
they're tickers for life and tickers
make you miserable you know look at a
stock ticker look at kpis look at
revenue day to day hour to hour and
you're miserable you shouldn't have
those for your life yeah and i i should
say it's bad for business for me to say
this because this podcast and all of my
content and all everything i put out is
optimizations hacks shortcuts
you know ways to be better ways to
better yourself and this constant uh
curiosity about what are some other
things i could try to better myself what
are some other areas i want to be better
and what are some ways i could be better
and so i'm like juggling these two
things that are almost complete like
opposition um and like you know and i
and i'm not perfect on it either right
like i still wake up swipe over and
check the bitcoin price even though i
know it's this roller coaster and like
when it's red i'm starting my day off
with like you know a tiny jab and when
it's green i start my day off with this
this this great little delight that like
i don't control and so now my my first
mood is up to you know the conditions of
like you know [__] crypto prices
which is silly totally sean what do you
think what do you think people are going
to think of an episode like this i'll be
i'll be curious i'll be because
i i sometimes i get nervous about
talking about this [__] because i'm like
i don't want to pontificate too much i
don't want to like act like our way or
my way or your way is necessarily better
than any other way i get nervous about
like having like a guru productivity
vibe i get nervous i'm like and then i
also get nervous i'm like these people
just want like
money-making schemes let's just give it
to them um i'm very like
think about like chamath right why is
true math interesting he's interesting
because he goes you know he goes on cnbc
he talks about all this crazy investing
stuff and then he goes with kara swisher
and he like pours his heart out and he's
interesting and empathic well yeah and
like he doesn't give a [__]
yeah you do a disservice if you don't
show the negative side of all this stuff
at the same time because people will
just blindly think you know oh yeah
these guys have it all figured out and
we don't so i think we're all as
miserable as anyone else i think two
things is what you said i think you're
not giving the audience enough like the
people who really listen to this podcast
they they know this is not money making
schemes we just like we are shooting the
[__] about business stuff and we're kind
of business nerds and that's what they
like so it's not actually that they're
looking for
oh god i came to this to find my next
million dollar idea that's the like
surface level thing and then when you
get when you get through the door you
realize that's that's not it the second
thing is it's just like
like this feeling you're having like
what are people going to think of this
episode i'm riding myself of that that
question uh
that question doesn't come into my brain
anymore why because who really not at
all
i'm i'm not gonna be wearing red robes
he's gonna have his head shaved dude he
already does she shows up to the podcast
half the time wearing a robe exactly uh
that's i'm not saying i have rid myself
of it i'm saying i am trying to rid
myself of that uh of that question right
and it's coming up less and less why
because two things
hey i don't want to be that way i don't
want to sit here and
be the dancing monkey performing on the
stage just just for their entertainment
i want to be here for my entertainment
and um like who are the people who are
going to love this podcast the people
who love what we talk about period so if
we're talking about something we are
interested in that they're
always going to be into it and if we
just keep that as the method right who
are my customers the people that love
what i do that becomes the sort of like
the the the most joyful way to do you
know any kind of business or any kind of
product because
it is just you pushed out and so then
you don't have to worry about what are
they going to want did they like me do
they not like me is this good is this
bad you know i liked it but are they
going to think this it's like
those questions just disappear if you
commit to
uh who are my customers the people that
love what i do so same thing for this
who who are listeners the people that
like what we talk about period so then i
don't need to if if i liked what we
talked about then i don't need to worry
about it and that becomes a very simple
filter that's internal and not like
seeking kind of what what are other
people going to think about this yeah
yeah yeah and and you and i agree on a
lot of stuff about how we feel about the
audience i guess sometimes i think of it
like i'm going to do whatever the hell i
want to do and other times i do think i
am here i exist to serve like others
right so like you could say like well
just don't give a [__] don't give don't
care about what other people think yeah
i but what if i phrased it of like well
i'm i'm here to service other people or
you know what i mean it's like that
and that's a fine line
andrew's saying
one of the things one of the top is
being you you know that's the service
the services being you in public public
transparently you know
lately i've been watching all the dave
chappelle stand up comedy from netflix i
just kind of like rediscovered him and
watched them all and if you watch the
first one it's kind of like a generic
dirty
stand-up
or yeah his old one from like 20 early
2017 or whatever and then as you watch
them they get more and more
introspective and darker and longer
stories and different style and it's
cool to see someone evolve or see some
you know deeper emotional range or
whatever so i don't i don't think it
really matters like at the end of the
day yes you guys you know this podcast
you do
i i listen i have to treat it like crack
right when i listen to you guys i get so
fired up i'm always in the shower and
i'm going [__] why don't we do that
business or i should start this or you
know i i love it but and that's that's
the that's what people love about the
podcast but at the same time like yeah i
think talking about this stuff is fine
like i think
look at a couple of the bigger podcasts
that are kind of like people we like to
listen to sometimes so look at rogan
do you think rogan gets on the pod every
day and says like do you think he's
thinking all right um
you know what do the people want like
what does the audience want how do i
make this conversation entertaining for
them like i think that's so far back in
his mind where it seems no
like he's just having a conversation
with somebody he finds interesting he
talks about what's interesting to him in
that thing but you know what if rogan
came on and he said i had a big fight
with my wife this morning and he started
talking about that for 30 minutes and
didn't let the guest talk yeah he's
broken the format yeah but but also with
rogan like you'll notice he like for
example um he'll say stuff like uh he
changes his words he's like well like
and i agree with this he'll be like well
you know i'm not informed on that topic
so i don't even want to rant about it of
course or he'll say like uh you know i
um like i'll notice how he'll use
certain words to be respectful um and
he's like well you know and people have
asked him i was like well i just didn't
know and i know that i influence people
so i just want to keep in mind that i
don't want to you know
say something incorrect and so that's
keep so i i i don't think you have to
entirely tell people to uh that you
don't give a [__] about that i guess
what i mean is like
rogan's format where he's like yeah i'm
going to talk to an astrophysicist one
day and then i'm going to talk to an mma
meathead the next day and then i'm going
to
do a drinking podcast with my buddies
while we watch some other [__] that you
don't get you're not looking at i'm just
looking at i'm going to talk out loud
and i'm going to do it for
i'm going to do three hour long episodes
yeah dude but rogan's a [__] comedian
his whole shtick is that he gets in
front of people and like comedians are
inherently like the most neediest people
he gets on a stage and like it needs
them to laugh and reply and if he bombs
he feels bad
what i'm saying is his show broke a
bunch of rules that other people would
have had our episode should be one hour
you should have like this you know like
this intro you shouldn't one day be
talking about one topic and then you're
the the people who want to hear neil
degrasse tyson don't care about brendan
shaw or whatever else sure and then you
have like like lex friedman huge huge
podcast his channel he's created and the
guy's talking about the nerdiest of the
nerdiest subjects in the most like
monotone voice right so it's like he's
not mr charisma he's not um talking
about uh pop culture and like other
topic because he's not
he found the balance of doing what's
interesting to him in his normal
personality um and i just think that's
just like a better way to go than
yeah i'm just trying to say don't don't
act like rogan's not human and has the
same insecurities and like well i want
to please people i want to look oh wow
bernie did really well i should do
bernie more often you know like [__]
like that
actually yeah i don't buy i don't buy
that you don't care like i think
everybody cares you can say it and i i
get what you mean like you know that
should be the attitude going into it but
it is unavoidable sure i think like well
we all give a [__] how we're perceived
and we'd all be choked if you know i i
made that tweet the other day and um i
got a i got a message from a friend that
said are you sure you want to tweet that
right because he'd gotten some messages
from people saying oh my god andrew's
having a mental breakdown on twitter he
said are you sure you want to tweet that
yeah you said are you sure you want to
tweet that and i was like oh my god have
i made this terrible yeah [__] that's
why i tweeted it yeah i know
yeah resonated with lots of people it
got lots of traction and got lots of
nice notes about it but um you know it's
it's scary putting putting this stuff
out there
yeah i i
i don't find that stuff to be scary but
that's weird when someone says i hate i
would hate that interaction are you sure
you want to tweet that yeah dude i just
like it took me like an hour to write
that i'm [__] sure it's a double down
for sam it's like
you know what like i'm going to double
down on that now
yeah i want a friend to text me that if
they actually think that though like i
think that's a valuable service right
yeah no i don't but uh
that's okay different breads
i i i like also if i have a friend my
friend jack sometimes i'll tweet stuff
and he'll like
reply like that's not true or like what
are you like he'll like argue with me
and i'll tweet i'll text him i go jack
don't argue with me in public
like don't don't you dare like
like what time
he like brothers do that sometimes
drives me crazy oh dude i'm like we're
family this stays in the family don't
you don't you [__] you defend me you
you laid out a traffic for me as i will
for you you don't talk you don't argue
with me in public
he always [__] does that like one
time i tweeted out the the numbers of
the podcast and he was like um but like
megaphone is wrong or he said something
like uh he's like oh but you count
youtube that kind of like uh that's not
really a dollar he said something like
that i don't even remember what it was
and i'm like well what the [__] jack
just like shut up
i'm like just text me but we're not
going to argue in public
you're supposed to
i don't even know how we got on that but
anyway my point was not bringing up that
we shouldn't do this stuff i'm just
curious just to hear what what the
feedback is
we care about feedback i care about i'll
take care of myself i care about
feedback
tweet at us and uh you can test me and
see if i respond to any of it and fail
my uh i think so how how often are you
keeping this how often are you holding
your phone how often do you use your
phone
oh well i'm basically i'm down from six
hours a day of screen time to two just
over two hours and i'm basically just
around random days i've just been taking
my apple watch so if i have a zoom call
or something i'll take my phone but if i
don't i'll just bring my apple watch and
it's been strangely freeing right
because you look i can still see the
text and i can get the calls what is it
apple watch to airpod
yeah i watched the airplane and if i'm
texting i've got to do this stupid
scratch or siri and so it's just not fun
to text and so i just don't do it andrew
one other thing you met steve jobs
yeah i met steve jobs tell me what that
was what happened
well so a lot of people don't know this
but when i was 15 my very first business
was a website with an incredibly
embarrassing nerdy name it was called
mac teens.com and it was me and a kid
from hawaii and another canadian kid and
we all made this tech news website
and
we started writing you know reviews and
news and all that kind of stuff um and
we started getting a lot of traffic and
like breaking apple rumors and stuff and
i ended up getting invited to go to mac
world as like a member of the press and
you know i got invited to this tour of
the apple store in new york when that
was a you know it was brand new it was
the first one i think and so i walk into
this tour and i think like we're just
going to get some pr flack touring us
around and i'm standing outside waiting
and a limousine rolls up and it's steve
jobs
and he gets out and he shakes my hand
and i'm you know 15 the guy's my hero
i've read every single biography of him
i'm like a quivering mess and i spent
the next hour me and like five other
journalists getting toured around the
apple store with steve jobs and i just
asked a bunch of questions about you
know about the products they're
releasing it was like a pr thing so it's
not like i got to ask him deep questions
but it was pretty freaking cool on the
bucket list and what was his like uh
presence like or how did he treat people
or what did you kind of take away from
from
just being around him well i mean you
gotta remember he was he was in steve
jobs pr you know mac world ceo mode so
he was just incredibly polished i
remember he was talking about uh the cd
burner in the 17-inch imac and i was
like enraptured it's a [__] like oem
cd burner right but he's making it sound
like it's the greatest thing in the
world i mean you know the reality
distortion field is obviously real um
and yeah he's just an amazing amazing
guy and it was it was cool to me did you
read this story that this guy tweeted
out yesterday i thought you might have a
story uh related to this this guy his
tweet kind of went viral about
he was trying to sell his company to
steve jobs and he [__] up did you read
this
no like i said it's the guy who was what
happened ceo of ilike which was like a
kind of like a music discovery service
kind of like in the early yeah you know
like startup days
and um it was like a popular service
and um it's like apple wanted to apple
was interested in acquiring them and
he's like perfect like apple would be my
dream place to get acquired and they go
and he gets to have a meeting with steve
jobs and he sits in the meeting with
steve jobs and he's like you know i
started off a little rough because i was
so nervous to be in front of steve jobs
he's like but we kind of hit our groove
in the presentation we hit our demo like
you know like first he's like the demo
kind of went off the rails first because
the executive suite wi-fi was down and
it's like oh [__] how are we we're not
on the internet how do we do our demo
well we like recovered
and steve asked a few questions while we
were talking but we had great product
answers and you could just tell he was
digging it and um
so his story is basically that at the
end of the the meeting he was like look
like i think you guys are great um and i
think you built something something good
here uh you know we'd like to buy your
company i'm gonna
um you know like like i'd like to buy
your company we're i'll talk to eddie
and we'll figure out you know eddie will
take it from here he'll he'll deal with
the details
and uh
and then he's like see the guy like kind
of didn't want the meeting to end right
there he's you know first he's like
that's amazing but he's like you know
like what uh what range you know would
you be thinking about for for price for
for an acquisition
and then like steve kind of like the
dial the dial like turns up a little bit
like this conference gets a little more
serious talking about the price now
and he's like um
he's like what's your revenue and how
much did you raise what was the
valuation at your last financing
and the guy's like uh like you know
revenue uh like we haven't we're
pre-revenue we're super small right now
but you know we we raised that 50
million valuation and we've added like
like millions of users since then um i
think he said 50 million users since
then which is some absurd number and uh
and steve jobs like
uh we probably acquire it for 50 million
and then the guys like went from this
high of like steve jobs just said he
wants to buy my company to like oh [__]
we've been working like since the last
round we raised two years ago we've been
working acquired all these users um i'd
have to go to my team and be like hey
you've created essentially no value
between last valuation and and the exit
here um
so he's like you know doesn't want it to
just leave it there and he's like um
he's like uh you know i just think i
don't think my team will be i don't i
don't think my team or the investors
would uh
you know that would be acceptable to
them
and then he's like he's like we'll make
it he's like we'll like we'll convince
them
like that was like steve jobs response
something like that and the guy's like
you know i just feel like
um you know i think we're worth more
than that i think we're i think we're
worth 150 million
and he like pause for a second he goes
actually like i know we're worth i know
we're worth 150 million
and he's like jobs got like pissed he's
like you know
do you have another offer on the table
have you been offered 150 million
dollars
but is that how you know that you're
worth that and then the guy's like just
pause for something he's like he's like
[__] he's like you're a liar and
he's like he's like forget this we're
not doing this deal and basically like
walked out and then he's like
we tried to salvage the deal like we
tried to like with eddie eddie tried to
like make it all good he's like steve
jobs called him later it was like i
don't trust you you you i don't trust
you i think you're a liar you know over
you overstated like you know ever you
overplayed your hand basically and i was
like we're not doing this oh i love that
that is awesome who wrote that oh wow
what company that is an awesome story
this guy uh let me pull up his name so
his name is ali
uh partavi so his his twitter handle is
a-p-a-a-a apart ovi so a-p-a-r-t ovi
what what ended up happening to his
company that did it so i think uh let's
see what what ended up happening so it's
what a baller story i think that's
like soon after that apple released the
itunes genius sidebar it was a rip-off
of their thing facebook copied their
thing and they sold the company for a
loss within a year um that was the sort
of like the oh my god
the other good one is drew the story of
drew houston going into they were
talking about dropbox apple and steve
jobs just starts saying feature not a
product you're a feature not a product
we can just rip you off and i mean in
some ways steve jobs is right i think
that criticism is fair over the next
decade couldn't rip them off though it'd
be irrelevant but at the same time drew
houston went on to become a billionaire
and build this great public company so
dude i actually i love stories where
steve jobs is wrong because
the guys it was like a [__] [__]
like you know he [__] that guy was he
a brilliant yeah but like i was thinking
the other day um where he like had this
quote where he goes to that guy who uh
who was selling pepsi and he was like do
you want to sell sugar or water your
whole life
or do you want to come and change the
world and i'm like part of me is like
badass that's awesome steve good job
yeah soda sucks
whatever you're doing is doesn't suck
and then i'm like dog what you've just
created is [__] candy
you know
if we hate if i if i'm supposed to hate
zuckerberg i should dislike you too like
you're selling the crack pipe he's
selling the crack what's the difference
and so
you know what i mean like
it's like it's the same it's like it's
the same thing like so so anyway
whenever i hear these stories about him
and being arrogant i'm like yeah you're
badass you're awesome you're always
right and then also like
you're a dick shut the [__] up like i
was i was as a ceo i was terrible
because i couldn't do that right like
imagine sam you're hiring someone and
you say like do you want to change the
face of publishing forever right you
just sound like such a douche but you
talk to most silicon valley ceos and
they say something like that i just
could never bring myself to say that
well part of me is envious i'm like oh
wow you actually believe that you are
doing something and then part of me is
like um
um
you're full of it i just read this book
uh called endurance have you guys heard
of this book called endurance oh my god
it's amazing it's i never want to feel
like your life is good read that oh my
god i couldn't put it down sean you know
what it is i haven't read it but i've
never seen the tie i've seen the cover i
know the cover in my brain so basically
in the early 1900s probably between 1900
and like 1925 it was called like the
heroic era of arctic expeditions so they
had steam engines and they had
combustible engines but it was still
they still had sails and they didn't
have radios and so these guys would sail
from england all the way down to
antarctica the very southern part of the
world to try and figure things out the
world wasn't really well mapped out but
it kind of was so basically it was kind
of safe but mostly not safe and this guy
named ernest shackleton basically led
this expedition of 30 people and they
got stuck in the ant in antarctica and
it's basically the story about their two
and a half year or maybe two year
expedition to survive and what i learned
reading that book is basically the pack
the the the people you're leading they
mimic the behavior of the leader and so
for a while i was against this like
we're gonna change the world or like you
know i should be vulnerable and i should
let people know like you know things
aren't going that good but now after
reading that book i'm like ah no [__] it
you gotta like convince everyone that
it's gonna be okay no matter what
totally it's an amazing book too i am
when i get stressed out at work one of
the things i love to do is to watch um
uh
what is it called alone have you guys
seen that show they literally dump
people in the middle of nowhere and it's
competition to see who can survive in
the wilderness all by themselves for the
longest oh my god you know you're
watching people eating rats and like
trying to catch fish in the freezing
cold how long do they last he
cuts his leg open with a hatchet or
whatever you know usually it's like some
some people go like three months four
months six months but a lot of people
are out pretty quick and the the
shackleton book is exactly like that i
watch it and i just feel so relaxed
because i'll be cozy on the couch and
warm in my bed reading the book and it
really makes you appreciate uh just how
comfortable our lives are you should
read that book sean so we could talk
about it because it like i read it over
uh two days i think it it it was it it's
riveting i i posted really it was crazy
i can't believe that that that people
survived that and it made me feel
thankful and it showed me that like in
order to be a leader you do need to
convince people
and yourself that everything's going to
be okay when i read that i was like i
don't want to be a good leader i'm not
willing to do what this guy was willing
to do am i willing to go this far
something funny just happened on twitter
so uh
speaking of distractions and and all
that good stuff and speaking of the the
memetic kind of like uh who are your
models and then who do you want to see
who do you not like to see win all right
so
uh so bezos jeff bezos just tweeted out
this thing he goes
uh he goes you know you should listen
and be open but don't let anybody tell
you who you are this is just one of the
many that this was and he posted a photo
of a baron's article of a headline of a
front page of barons which says
amazon.bomb and it's a picture of jeff
bezos's face on a bomb and it says that
the title is the idea that amazon's ceo
jeff bezos has pioneered a new business
is silly he's just another middleman and
the stock market is starting to catch on
the real winners this was in like the
early 2000's yeah this is in um i don't
know when sorry go ahead giannis or
something like that oh yeah this is
1999. he goes
uh it says the real winners on the net
and it's like apostrophe net like
internet uh the real winners on the net
will be firms that sell their own
products directly to consumers just look
what happened to sony and dell that's
what's gonna happen to amazon
and uh
and so bezos was basically saying like
you know people told us there's one of
many things where people told us we're
gonna fail he goes today amazon is one
of the most successful companies and has
revolutionized two entirely different
industries
and then elon musk tweeted that it
replied with just a silver a silver
medal with the number two on it like the
emoji with a place
[Laughter]
you gotta give them because elon's
currently richer than bezos either
because of that i don't know space yeah
it's doing better than you know
i think it's the rich thing which is
douchey if it's a space thing that's not
douchey if it's a rich thing that's
douchey but it's so funny because you
were cinematic right those guys were in
a rivalry yeah you were saying like to
us jeff bezos is not really the rival we
don't really root for his you know
whatever uh it doesn't like hurt us
personally when jeff bezos wins a little
bit more but but for these guys these
are their memetic rivals right like
these are their their peers
uh that they sort of are in competition
with
but dude also this is i do want to see
elon lose a little bit because he gets
too smug with his help gradius be smart
because he is in fact amazing
but how baller is that tweet hilarious
it has way more like you said earlier
you said you know you said [__] steve
jobs and i think in order to be that
successful you have to have some kind of
personality disorder oh yeah or like
yeah or something and you look at musk
or bezos or if you read more about bezos
i think he's a really difficult person
to work for
like all these guys are so complicated
and a hundred years ago you just
wouldn't know there wasn't twitter you
just wouldn't see this this would all go
on behind the scenes and it's crazy that
we get to see stuff like that well i
don't even think it's that complicated
musk is really successful because he's
incredibly smart and has a a complex
because his father probably didn't love
him um like
like it's probably quite simple
and but it's it works right i'm thankful
that well
that's uh great i think i don't know
where you got it from but you know show
me a great man and i'll show you a bad
man what is that quote well i always say
um i don't know if i got it from
anywhere not but uh all men are also
evil men all great great and like
something like that right
yeah great men are bad men um and in
order to in order to be great you have
to do bad stuff or
you may not think it's bad but like
let's say that like uh 60 of americans
think obama is a saint well like the
people who he droned they don't think
he's a saint i've got afghani friends
and they'll be like oh i [__] hate
obama you know he he droned my family
and so but like so in order to like do
great [__] and be loved by at a large
scale you're going to piss off a lot of
people the way i would put it it would
be better might be
all but great men are sad men right so
they have a sadness don't want to help
me andrew don't want to be a disorder
that's driving to do this because why
else would anyone do it right talking
about the shackleton expedition these
guys are the shackleton expedition of
business why would anyone choose to do
that unless they have a personality
disorder or like deep trauma right but
memetic rivalry andrew just went up to
you perfect uh yeah like actually i
think your example of like obama drone
striking people is a little too extreme
i think it's more like uh elon musk
isn't a is a great inventor and
businessman uh that doesn't also mean
he's got great views on the vaccine and
uh on he's not a great husband maybe and
like yeah you know
we will praise somebody for an aspect
like on this podcast i will happily pray
somebody for an aspect of something they
do that's interesting like this is like
the jake paul tweet i did where i was
like jake paul is a great marketer a
great self-promoter like i don't even
think that's arguable like i think he's
clearly a great self-promoter that is
how he is so famous as he promoted
himself uh into fame
and uh like people are like yeah but he
you know he's accused of assault on this
girl and like he's a jerk and like
haven't you seen these videos where he
makes these crew jokes i said oh like
sorry did i say he's my like he's my
hero and that like he is a great
boyfriend like i don't think i said that
i think he said he's a great marketer
and self-promoter and you can learn from
right i appreciate that and that's the
way i take it which is
um you know
anybody that that you praise or you call
out for being awesome or call out for
being bad it's not you're not saying
they are either all great or all bad
it's like
they are great in ways and bad in ways
and everybody is that and it's not even
that you need to get point
you can like how he builds cars but not
how he treats his marriage right yeah
[Music]
you